Je n’aurais vraiment pas dit qu’il y avait 206 os dans le corps humain.
Ouais, alors en fait ce qui est rigolo, c’est que,
on en a plus à la naissance qu’à l’âge adulte.
Parce qu’en fait, les ossements, pour grandir, poussent par différents bouts.
T’as un bout central et deux extrémités, par exemple, pour faire un ossement.
Et chaque petit noyau va grandir, grandir, grandir et se rejoindre,
mais au début, tu as deux petits noyaux, trois petits noyaux osseux qui sont reliés par du cartilage.
Et au fur et à mesure, ce cartilage va s'agrandir et s’ossifier.
C’est pour ça que quand tu nais, tu as 350 os chez un bébé,
et puis chez un adulte, tu en as que 206.
Ce qui est d’ailleurs assez utile,
parce que par exemple, la boîte crânienne, chez un adulte, c’est un seul os
et chez un bébé, c’est plein de petits os avec du cartilage entre les deux.
Et au moment d’accoucher, c’est quand même bien pratique parce que les os du crâne peuvent se superposer légèrement au moment du passage,
et du coup, ça réduit légèrement la circonférence de la tête du bébé, même si ça reste compliqué à passer.
C’est un peu plus facile.
Et en fait, ce qui est rigolo, c’est que, ces ossements, plus tu grandis, moins tu en as donc, puisque plus ils se soudent les uns avec les autres.
Et c’est une manière qu’on a en archéologie de déterminer l’âge d’un squelette.
C’est pour ça que quand tu as terminé ta croissance,
tu ne peux plus déterminer l’âge de la mort de quelqu’un à l’année près.
- Avant, c’est possible.
- Ok.
Et par exemple, y a un truc qui est sympa aussi, que je répétais souvent à mes étudiants et qui les faisait pas mal rire.
Tu sais quand on est au collège, au lycée, on dit :
“Ouais, les filles sont vachement plus matures que les garçons”.
Et bah en fait, c’est vrai, le dernier os à se souder, c’est la clavicule
et chez une fille, ça se soude deux à un an plus tôt que chez les garçons.
Donc c’est vrai qu’on est adulte plus rapidement, tu vois.
Du coup, ouais, quand tu dates un squelette, tu dois savoir si c’est un mâle ou une femelle avant.
Effectivement, tu as besoin de savoir si c’est un homme ou une femme pour faire une estimation la plus précise possible.
Après, il y a différentes tables, différentes écoles tu sais.
En fonction de la table que tu choisis, tu peux avoir 5 ans de différence sur une estimation.
Ce qui est assez énorme.
Et surtout, c’est que les anciennes tables ne prenaient en compte que l'ostéologie, l’anatomie.
Maintenant, on a des scanners qui nous permettent
d’être beaucoup plus précis sur la différence de croissance justement entre les filles et les garçons,
et aussi en fonction de ta génétique.
Parce que les populations ont des rythmes de croissance légèrement différents.
Donc voilà.
Et après, une fois que tu ne peux plus dater l’âge de ton squelette,
qu’est-ce que tu fais pour savoir quel âge il a, tu utilises ce qu’on appelle des indices de sénescence.
C'est-à-dire, des indices comme quoi le squelette est en train de vieillir.
Tu as l'arthrite, le tassement lombaire, ce genre de choses.
Mais c’est pour les vieux ça du coup ? L’âge intermédiaire, l’âge adulte, tu fais comment ?
Tu peux pas.
C’est pour ça que dans beaucoup de documentaires, quand tu as des voix-off qui te disent :
“Nous retrouvons le squelette d’une femme morte à 37 ans”.
Tu dis non, tu peux pas en fait.
Morte entre l’âge adulte et le début de la vieillesse.
Et puis la vieillesse, c’est très différent d’une personne à l’autre en fonction de ton activité, de ton état de santé.
Il y a quelque chose qui pourrait quand même t’intéresser.
C’est qu’en archéologie, on a beaucoup utilisé l’usure dentaire
pour essayer de donner l’âge des plus anciens, des plus vieux.
Le truc, c’est que l’usure dentaire,
c’est que c’est pas uniquement corrélé à ton alimentation.
C’est aussi corrélé à l’activité que tu peux avoir, il y a beaucoup de population qui utilise les dents comme un outil.
Par exemple, les Inuits travaillent le cuir avec les incisives. Elles ont les incisives complètement rabotées.
Ce n'est pas une histoire de vieillesse, c’est juste une histoire de travail manuel.
Et il y autre chose qui entre en compte, c’est la manière avec laquelle tu vas créer ta farine.
Parce qu’en fonction de la pierre que tu vas choisir pour meuler ta farine,
tu vas avoir plus ou moins d’inclusions minérales à l’intérieur de ta farine,
et donc passer ton temps, ta vie à manger des petits bouts de minéraux dedans.
Est-ce que ça peut être bon pour la santé ou pas de manger des bouts de minéraux ?
Ça, j’en sais rien du tout. C’est marrant ça.
Y a des pierres qui perdent plus facilement des bouts que d’autres ou pas ?
Oui, je pense que si tu as du grès, le grès, c’est du sable induré, les petits grains ils doivent partir rapidement.
Mais après, les pierres que l’on utilise pour meuler, je ne sais absolument pas en quoi c’est pour le coup.
C’est marrant que ça perde…
En fait, tu peux utiliser n’importe quoi pour créer une meule. Tu peux utiliser du granit, tu peux utiliser du grès.
C’est vrai que nous, on en trouve beaucoup en granit.
Mais en fonction de la dureté de la pierre, potentiellement, tu vas avoir dans ton pain des petits bouts
de ta meule qui vont contribuer à t’user les dents et donc à te faire paraître plus âgé aux yeux des archéologues.
C’est marrant ça. Du coup, est-ce que ça peut intervenir aussi dans l’alimentation, genre, c’est comme si tu prenais un complément alimentaire en minéral ?
Alors ça, c’est intéressant, il y a des populations qui effectivement broient les minéraux pour en ingérer.
Et il y a d’ailleurs une histoire en archéologie sud-américaine qui nous embête beaucoup avec ça.
C’est que les petits singes sud-américains, ils ont besoin de se complémenter en minéraux,
et donc ils cassent les cailloux pour les lécher. Ils les cassent donc intentionnellement.
Donc les cailloux sont cassés intentionnellement, mais pas pour créer un outil, mais pour récupérer des oligo-éléments.
Sauf que dans les matériels archéologiques, il y a des archéologues qui confondent ces cassures de singe
avec des cassures des premiers hommes amérindiens.
- Donc, ça pose un véritable problème de méthodologie.
- C'est pas top ça.
Comment tu fais la différence ?
- Hola, alors là,...
- Pardon, c'est une question trop...
Non, en vrai, je peux répondre.
Quand tu caches un caillou juste pour aller chercher un oligo-élément, la seule chose que tu veux faire, c’est l’ouvrir en deux.
Donc, tu t’en fous de l’axe, tout ça.
Exactement. Alors que si tu veux un caillou pour faire quelque chose, tu as forcément au moins une envie de tranchant,
ou au moins une envie de partie active qui généralement est un tranchant, mais qui peut aussi être une petite pointe pour percer, ou quelque chose pour racler.
Et généralement, ce tranchant, il va être opposé à une partie que tu peux tenir.
Parce qu’évidemment, si tout est tranchant, tu te retrouves à te couper les doigts ou à devoir créer une anse un petit peu bizarre.
Mais généralement, l’intuition du tailleur de pierre, c’est d’avoir une partie qu’on appelle préhensive,
qui est confortable pour ta main et de l’autre côté, une partie active.
- Comme sur nos couteaux quoi, il n’y a pas que la lame.-
- Exactement, comme sur nos couteaux.
Cool, c’est incroyable ça.
C’est marrant que tu aies surtout trouvé des meules en granit.
Parce que… non en même temps, c’est complètement logique parce que le granit, c’est une pierre ultra compétente, on dit, donc très dure.
Et le but d’une meule, c’est de presser un grain pour l’écraser, c’est normal de le faire contre un truc dur plutôt qu’un truc mou.
Genre, si tu fais ça sur du talc, c’est complétement mou, tu sais, le talc roche, à la base, ça s’appelle de la stéatite
et ça c’est vraiment complètement mou, genre limite tu peux le tordre, et tout, c’est assez marrant.
Ça, pour une meule, ça serait pas top effectivement.
La stéatite, c’est bien le machin qu’on appelle aussi pierre à savon ?
- Ça doit être un truc dans le genre ouais.
- Et tu en as plusieurs couleurs.
Ouais, je crois qu’il y en a un peu verte, en Amérique Centrale, il y a ce genre de trucs.
J’ai une petite statuette chez moi qui vient d’Amérique Centrale en stéatite, et du coup, il y a plein de traces d’ongles en dessous parce que…
- Ah c’est tendre à ce point-là en fait ?
- Oui, c'est tendre.
Le principe vraiment, c’est que tu peux le rayer, faire des traces comme dans du beurre en gros.
- Excellent.
- Ouais, c'est hyper cool.
Mais ça doit être hyper pratique pour faire des œuvres d’art.
Ouais j’imagine, mais bon, celle là elle est un peu ruinée à cause de moi…